네 오늘 새벽의 남자 김단태 왔고요
이번 주말에도 여행을 잠깐 온 상태인데
전쟁이 끝날 여지가 보이고 있습니다
요새 계속 육가로 제가 영상을 시작하게 되는데
WTI는 이제 80불 때
그것도 80불 깰 수도 있을 것처럼 내려왔고요
브렌트유도 88달러가 됐습니다
육가를 80달러 때를 보는 것도 오랜만이고
이게 80달러가 깨질 수도 있다라는 얘기를 하는 게
정말 오랜만입니다
전쟁의 분위기가 드라마틱하게 바뀌었다고
시장에서 느끼는 것 같아요
사실 주가가 올라와도 육가가 계속 내려오지 못했기 때문에
불안한 점들이 좀 있었는데
그런 불안한 점들을 좀 해소해주는 그런 시장이었다
라고 볼 수가 있겠고요
현재 나스닥 1.65% 상승하고 있고
다우 S&P 러셀 전부 다 1%에서 2%
매우 강하게 상승하고 있습니다
어떤 종목들이 올랐는지를 봐도
상당히 긍정적이었습니다
사실 대부분의 종목들이 올랐어요
에너지랑 유틸리티 주식들
그러니까 육가로 인해서 수혜를 받던 종목들만
거의 다 하락을 했고
대부분의 종목은 다 상승을 했습니다
상당히 긍정적인 분위기
세부 종목들도 그런 분위기라고 할 수가 있겠고요
제일 큰 건 바로 이거죠
오후 9시쯤 나왔던 아라그치 외교부 장관의 선언이었는데
휴전 잔여 기간 동안
호르무즈 해업이 완전히 없어졌습니다
휴전 잔여 기간 동안 호르무즈 해업이 완전히 없어졌습니다
휴전이 개방된다고 선언을 했습니다
이게 일단 시장에 정말 큰 영향을 줬고요
물론 이란에서 호르무즈 해업을 개방한다고 했지만
실제로 배들이 움직이는 건 아니에요
배들 입장에서도 계속 이랬다 저랬다 하니까
정말 명확할 때까지는 움직이기가 좀 거시기 하겠죠
그래서 명확한 입장을 기다리고 있고
그러다 보니까 배들이 실제로 움직이는 건 아니지만
어쨌든 시장에서는 상당히 의미가 있다
라고 보고 있습니다
실제 배가 움직이고 안 움직이고를 떠나서
외교적인 의미가 더 클 수 있다라는 거죠
왜냐하면 이런 거 자체가
나는 대화에 열려있다라는 그런 시그널을
트럼프에게 주는 거기 때문이죠
다만 트럼프는 이렇게 얘기를 했습니다
여전히 호르무즈 해업이 개방이 됐다라고 해도
미국의 봉쇄는 계속 된다라고 얘기를 한 상황
그래서 지도를 보시면
여기가 이란이고 여기가 호르무즈 해업인데
미국이 봉쇄하고 있는 곳은 이쪽입니다
당연히 이란 쪽에서 봉쇄를 할 수는 없으니까
더 바깥으로 나와서 봉쇄를 하고 있고
어쨌든 간에 미국의 봉쇄는 계속 된다라고
트럼프가 얘기를 했지만
사실 이 얘기 자체가 뭐랄까요
이란에 대해서 압박을 하는 그런 제스처 정도로 느껴야지
트럼프는 그 누구보다도 봉쇄를 풀고 싶다는 거를 알고 있기 때문에
이런 트럼프의 이야기 자체는 시장에 주는 영향이 적었다라고 볼 수가 있겠고요
그 외에도 트럼프는 뭐랄까
항상 좀 방구석 여포 같죠
무슨 말이냐면
이란이 또 핵 프로그램을 무기한 중단하기로 합의를 했으며
미국으로부터 동결된 자금 역시 받지 못할 것이라고 말했습니다
그래서 트럼프 대통령이 몇 시간 전에 있었던 전화 인터뷰에서
이제 이 전쟁을 끝나기 위한
합의가 대부분 마무리됐다라고 하면서
이런 얘기들을 한 건데
트럼프 대통령이 워낙 말을 세게 하니까
이럴 수도 있겠구나
뭐 이 정도로 생각해야 되지 않을까
트럼프는 말을 이렇게 했지만
실제 협상은 이것보다는 더 못 가져가지 않을까
뭐 저는 이런 생각을 가지고 있긴 합니다
어쨌든 간에 뭔가 협상이 진행되고 있구나
정도로 우리는 시그널을 받으면 될 것 같고요
트럼프야 뭐 이렇게 세게 얘기를 했지만
이란 입장에서 핵 프로그램에 대해서
양보를 하는 게 아니라
이런 얘기가 없었기 때문에
트럼프 말을 고지곳대로 들을 필요는 없을 것 같고
다만 이제 마지막 협상 라운드를 위해서
트럼프가 직접 파키스탄으로 갈 수도 있다
이런 식으로 답을 했기 때문에
의미 있는 협상이 진행이 되는 거 아닌가
이런 생각이 들기는 했습니다
어쨌든 이런 상황 자체가 시장에선 다 긍정적이죠
대화를 하고 있다라는 거고
양측은 협상에 열려있다라고 볼 수가 있기 때문이죠
그래서 저도 개인적으로 든 생각은
이제 진짜 전쟁은 8분 응선을 넘은 게 아닌가
유가도 정말 80불까지 내려왔고
8분 응선 넘은 상황으로 봐야 되지 않을까
이런 생각이 있습니다
특히나 뭐 미국은 당연히 협상에 의지가 있었고
이스라엘이 좀 문제였는데
이스라엘의 문제도 좀 잠잠해지는 상황에서
이란 역시 협상에 의지를 보이고 있기 때문에
아무래도 저는 이제 미국의 이란 앞바다
봉쇄가 한 몫을 한 거 같긴 한데
왜냐하면 어쨌든 간에
미국이 봉쇄를 그쪽을 정말 제대로 하기 시작을 하면
이란도 꽤 골치가 아플 수가 있거든요
이란도 호르무즈 해협을 지나서
이란 쪽 바다로 나와서
거기서 이제 팔아먹는 기름들이 있기 때문에
그게 대부분 중국으로 가는데
그 물량들이 위기에 처할 수가 있기 때문에
이란도 그리고 또 전쟁도 많이 했고
그러다 보니까 이란도 협상에 열려 있는 그런 모습 보이고
그래서 전쟁 어쨌든 이란도 곤란해지면서
이스라엘만 말썽을 안 일으킨다면
이대로 좀 마무리가 될 수도 있는 거 아닌가 라는 생각
시장의 모습도 역시나 비슷한 모습을 보이고 있습니다
자 그래서 전쟁에 대한 얘기
이 정도로 정리해 보고요
그리고 또 재밌는 거
미국의 데이터센터에 대한 투자가
지금까지 과거에 있었던 메가 프로젝트들과 비교했을 때
어떤 추세로 가고 있느냐 라는 관점에서 봤을 때는
상당히 좀 재밌었는데
GDP 랑 비교를 하면
미국 철도가 가장 많은 GDP 대비가 되었을 때가
가장 많은 GDP 대비 가장 큰 투자를 했고
사실 같은 투자 시점으로 봤을 때는
데이터센터의 투자가 그렇게 과도하지는 않아 보입니다
물론 금액 자체는 상당히 큰데
미국의 GDP가 상당히 올라왔음을 또 감안을 해야 되는 거기 때문에
이런 걸 봤을 때는
우리가 데이터센터 투자가 너무 지나치다 라는 얘기들이 있지만
맨하탄 프로젝트, 아폴로 프로그램
이런 것들과 당연히 비교할 수는 있는데
그래도 미국 철도 같은 또
상호적인 그런 투자에 비하면
이게 미국 철도에 투자가 되는 그런 속도거든요
이 그래프에 비하면
데이터센터 투자하는 거는 좀
그렇게 과도하지 않을 수도 있겠구나 라는 생각을 하게 됩니다
이게 계속 누적으로 쌓인 겁니다
참고로
결론적으로 데이터센터 투자
그렇게 과하지 않을 수도 있다 라고 보시면 될 것 같고요
자 그리고 엔트로픽
요즘에 다 깨부시고 다니고 있는
엔트로픽에서 클로드 디자인 이라는 걸 출시를 했어요
이거는 조금 더 디자인과 관련된 시각적인 결과물을
AI로 만들 수 있는
그것에 전문화된 AI다 라고 보시면 됩니다
저도 데모를 열심히 써본 건 아닌데
어쨌든 시장은 피그마 같은
보통 우리가 앱이나 웹 서비스 만들 때
사용하는 디자인 툴이거든요
피그마가 그런 대표적인 디자인 툴인
디자인 서비스를 하고 있는 피그마의 주가가
오늘 7%가 하락을 하고 있다
그러니까
다시 말해서 엔트로픽이 어떤 서비스를 내면
그 분야의 소프트웨어 회사들 주가가
폭락하는 상황이다 라고 볼 수가 있겠고요
개인적으로 클로드 코드를
요즘도 계속 사용하고 있는데
제가 느끼기에도
이런 사스의 폭락은 합당하다 라고 생각을 합니다
물론 소수의 사스 회사들은
소프트웨어 구독형 소프트웨어 회사들
살아남을 거라고 생각하고
자신만의 데이터가 있는
그런 사스 회사들은
자신만의 노하우가 있는 사스 회사들은
살아남겠지만
어쨌든 단기적으로는
시장이 그것을 구분하지 못할 거기 때문에
단기적으로는 모든 회사가 폭락을 할 거고
모든 회사가 실적과 상관없이 폭락을 하겠지만
그러다 보면은
정말 실적이 떨어지기 시작하는 회사들이 있을 거고
실적이 계속 버텨주는 회사들이 있을 건데
장기적으로는 버텨주는 회사는
그래도 시장이 살려주지 않을까
뭐 이런 생각을 하겠죠
그럼에도 불구하고
저는 이런 상황에서 굳이 사스를 투자를 하지는 않을 것 같습니다
왜냐면 일단은 시장이 그런 거 생각 없이
다 같이 떨어뜨리고 있으니까요
싸니까 산다라는 건
언제까지 싸질지 모르는 상황에서는
되게 위험한 전략이라고
저는 개인적으로 생각을 합니다
저는 투자와 관련된 블로그 하고 있고
투자와 관련된 인스타그램 하고 있습니다
관련된 건 고정 댓글과 설명란 참고 부탁드리고요
저는 또 돌아오겠습니다